as we near the start of the school year
the battle over whether it's safe to
reopen school buildings
is escalating the issue has led to
impassioned protests on both sides all
across the country
including in florida where the largest
teachers union is suing state officials
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in miami for us david good
morning there sure seems to be a lot at
stake here
yeah look tony this is arguably the
hottest hot spot florida is averaging
more deaths per day than any other state
in the country right now about 115 a day
despite that the governor is striking a
hopeful tone
saying he thinks things are going in the
right direction when it comes to
managing hospitalizations even though
some hospitals seem to be right on the
brink
as of yet the governor has not responded
to that lawsuit from teachers who are
essentially suing him
to stop him from forcing them to open up
schools but you know where the governor
is finding support on the idea of
reopening schools
from the president and the vice
president
the vice president mike pence is
encouraging parents to do what he says
he would do
if our kids were elementary school age
or high school or college we wouldn't
hesitate to send them back school
pence says children with no serious
underlying conditions
are at a low risk for getting covet 19
and dr
anthony fauci agrees that is true for
most kids
but some children do get seriously ill
and some do pass it on to the adults so
i think we have to be careful when we
talk about that
it can't be back to school with schools
as usual harvard professor
joseph allen specializes in public
health what are your thoughts on
reopening schools
well look i think there's some
conditions precedent first being that we
have to get cases under control in this
country allen says
in addition to hand washing and social
distancing it is imperative that schools
provide greater ventilation
with portable air cleaners that have
hepa filters in them
in every single classroom in the country
there is a risk to getting kids
back in school in an area that has high
cases you know what also is a massive
risk
devastating consequences to keeping kids
out of school
we've seen this with virtual dropouts we
see more sedentary activity
30 million plus kids in this country
rely on schools for food
so i had my mom and my brother and i see
you at the same time
back here in florida jakari byrd says
his brother jordan
was working as an elementary school
custodian and taking classes at a
community college in tallahassee
when he contracted covid19 he died
saturday
at the age of 19. he aids
in college so he was very talented
i miss him i mean he was just a gentle
giant
what did you want to be he wanted to be
educated
jordan was being treated for diabetes
before he contracted the coronavirus
he went into the hospital with his
mother they were both
in the icu he died his mother who turned
55 in the hospital gail
appears to have survived and was just
released to a rehab
facility boy david i'm glad she survived
but 19 is far too young it's not
supposed to work that way
thank you very much